hello and welcome to this video of Vlad
Dracula as my opponent that's only
playing blitz games and he plays Eve or
f6 oh nice
ok ok not quite sure what this is
supposed to do but ok again stuff like
that the best recipe is to just not
spend too much time and just play normal
looking development moves that is the
thing to do you sometimes can of course
immediately punish things and you should
try but what is this guy doing here ok
so what's going on here I would love to
go on to that long diag often to that
diagonal here this one B 3 and C 4 maybe
it's probably not so easy to to get down
and now I'm still starting to think for
no particular reason so just see for I
guess push the Queen back yeah now
Bishop to a5 instead of move I mean I
can also take on a vaild yeah probably
it's going to be the simplest way to
play and now yeah we are probably d5 you
cannot take it twice to to Bishop c4 and
I want to open the position as much as
possible 25 Bishop c4 just taking one
yeah probably just taking it and oh yeah
what is easiest Queen e2 may be
centralizing again I'm not afraid that
he takes that's just a deadly pin 95 to
ship C for you cannot survive
I'm a threatening anything in particular
Queenie five maybe 25 I mean it's just a
a good improvement move a bishop coming
to his six would be killing there is no
clear way of getting there I mean does
this make sense anyway so let's do it
way for a 5 then Bishop c4 it could be
could be enough I mean he has no decent
move anyway yeah I've got Queen yet just
winning the rook I don't know what the
purpose of such a game is really I mean
or was f6 and Mouse Club
I don't know wanted to go is 6 mm I
don't know well yeah here after he takes
that wins the d5 pawn so 97 here you
just get developed develop normally I'd
really know much to say I'm a kind of a
weird game maybe he's drunk or something
I think what can you do oh the engine
gives night 5 already and then Queenie
r3m okay let's that's true I was just
thinking okay Knight a for to threaten
95 and that was in fact ignored so I got
him
I had 97 okay I didn't even think about
that I was good silly not to do it I
know I don't care it's just like it's so
winning that you don't yeah
you don't need to play the absolutely
most precise moves the key I'm winning
the Roberto he has no way to defend this
position anyway maybe I have six while
the mouse slip the bonds defender this
nonsense even has a name that's funny
I have six the bonds defense anyway
thanks for watching